Now that our system is aware of what
all software is available, and the most
recent version numbers, it's now time
for us to actually update the software.
We do this with the command,
sudo apt-get upgrade.
Once again, we have to use sudo.
Remember this is an administrative task
that we have to run as the root user.
After a few seconds, you'll be presented
with a list of everything that's going
to change on your system.
And this question,
do you want to continue, yes or no?
We'll say yes in a second, but let's
review this information real quick.
Here we have a list of packages
that will be upgraded.
Some of these names look familiar.
See a name python here,
python down here.
But others, not so much.
This early in setting up a new machine,
you can be pretty safe in just accepting
that the system is always making
the best decisions for you.
Later on, when you actually have your
web application running on this system,
and it's serving your users.
You're going to want to take more
care in reviewing this list.
And testing everything in
a non-production environment
before performing similar operations
on your production server.
For now, we'll just hit yes and
we'll go take a coffee break as
all of these new versions
are downloaded and installed.